problem 36
use the diagram below to answer the
question that follows all right there's
my diagram a gift box has dimensions x
by y
by z
a decorative ribbon is wrapped across
the diagonals of the box as shown above
which of the following expressions
represents the approximate total length
of the ribbon
all right so let's just measure this
ribbon so what's this length
right here what's that length right
there well if we draw that side of the
box
the height is z
and the depth is y
and the ribbon goes from the bottom left
to the top right from the bottom left to
the top right
so we can use a pythagorean theorem
right here right because if this is if
this height is z then this height right
here is z so this is a right triangle
and so we can figure out the hypotenuse
using the pythagorean theorem so we
could say that the length right here
the length squared maybe i'll write it
like that the length squared is equal to
y squared plus z squared or the length
is equal to the square root of y squared
plus z squared that's this length right
here now we can use that exact same
argument on this side of the box over
here you can imagine just if we were to
face it well if you were to just turn it
around it would look exactly like this
or if you were to look at it from the
inside of the box if you were to look at
it from the inside of the box it would
look like this
it looks like this is the back of it
so if we're looking at it from this
direction it looks like this the height
is z
the base is y
and so we just have the hypotenuse y
squared plus z squared is going to be
equal to the length squared or the
length is equal to y squared plus the
square root of y squared plus z squared
so that's this length and that length so
so far if we just want to add up just
that length and that length we're going
to have 2
times each of them so 2 times the square
root of y squared
plus z squared that's the two red parts
of the ribbon
now
what is this length
right here
well same argument if i were to just
draw the base of this rectangle
the depth is y the width is x and the
ribbon just goes across it like that
the ribbon just goes across it like that
so if we call this the
length l of this blue part you have l
squared is equal to x squared plus y
squared or l is equal to the square root
of x squared
plus y squared
that's this length right there and then
this length over here might not look it
look the same because of the the way
that the perspective works but it's the
exact same thing it's the exact same
thing if this is x this depth is y
if you were to look at the box from the
top
this length is x the depth is y the top
ribbon looks like that so x squared plus
y squared is going to be equal to that
thing so this length is also the square
root of x squared plus y squared so
that's the square root of x squared plus
y squared this is the square root of x
squared plus y squared so in the total
length of the ribbon we're going to have
two of them plus 2 times the square root
of x squared plus y squared so the total
length of the ribbon 2 times the square
root of x squared plus y squared plus 2
times the square root of y squared plus
z squared now what is what let's see
that looks like choice
c they just factored the 2 out so it's 2
times everything square root of x
squared plus y squared plus the square
root of y squared plus z squared
right over there next problem
problem 37 use the graph below to answer
the question that follows all right we
have this little drawing of a hand
pointing up if the image of a pointy
hand in the graph above is rotated 180
degrees
about the origin and then reflected
across the x-axis which of the following
graphs will result so let's do it step
by step if you're rotated 180 degrees
you're rotating it
like this around the x-axis you're
rotating it like that so for example
this
square you can draw it you'll do it in a
lighter color
this right here this part of the hand is
going to rotate it all the way down so
it's going to look like
it's going to look like that right there
if i were to shade it in and then the
hand
this part right here is going to be
rotated all the way down like this
so the hand's going to look something
like this that's the thumb part
and then you're going to have the finger
coming out like this
the finger part the finger pointing up
and then you're going to have the other
finger so the hand's going to look
something like that when you rotate 180
degrees i just rotate it around the
origin
now the second part is then reflected
across the x-axis so then if we reflect
this across the x-axis it's going to
look like this it's going to look
something like
that like right there so that should be
our answer so which of the choices looks
like that
looks like
choice
c
choice c looks exactly what we drew up
here where the finger is closer the
finger is closer to the vertical axis
than it then then i guess the pinky is
in either case because we rotate it
around and then we flipped
and that is choice c
next question
problem 38 which of the following nets
can be folded to form a square pyramid
so square pyramid so this is all they're
giving us some visualization problem the
square pyramid is just a pyramid that
has a square as this base like the
pyramids in egypt so it has a square as
this base so it has a square as its base
so that's the square base let's see if i
can construct one if i were to fold this
guy up and then this guy up
then can this guy be the other side of
the pyramid no because if i fold this
guy up like this so unless they imagine
let's fold them up and so i have a
pyramid so this guy gets folded like
that
and then this guy over here
this guy over here
can he
fold in he's going to fold
straight down and fill that up so this
guy right here can fill that right there
maybe yeah let me use some colors and
then if this guy when i fold it will
fill right there
and then
and then when i and then this flap this
flap won't fill in the blank
this flap won't go where it's supposed
to that's it this flap will just recover
this flap again
so choice a is not the correct choice
let's see choice b
so if i flip this over that flap is just
going to go right there
so that flap is going to go right there
and then let's say this flap is going to
go over
right there
and then this flap
this flap right here let's see if this
flap this side right there is going to
be that side so this flap is going to go
right over on this side just like that
and then this last flap remember this
edge is that edge right there so this
last flap will just fill in the blank
right there so it looks like b works
well actually form
will actually form a rectangular or a
square pyramid let's see if these other
ones work before i rule them out
so this flap over here
this top flap when you flip it over is
going to i'm you can imagine looking at
the pyramid from the top
and then this edge over here we do it in
pink this edge over here would flip down
and fill up that edge but then this edge
right here will just when you fold this
we'll just go on top of that same edge
again and then this over here we'll just
go over top of this edge again so we're
only going a half the pyramid so that's
not going to work
this one you flip this one over
it's going to look like
that imagine looking at the pyramid from
above then you flip this one over
it's going to look switch colors
it's going to look like this
this part right here and then this piece
let me do it in let me do it in purple
this piece right here because this edge
is going to be this edge is going to
fill that right there but that's exactly
where this piece would go when you flip
it so we're not we're gonna have an
empty space right there so that also
doesn't work so b is our answer
next problem
use a figure below to answer the
question that follows okay that gives a
little triangle
if equilateral triangle abc well
equilateral tells us that all the sides
are equal represents one of two
congruent halves congruent mean
completely sides and angles are the same
congruent halves of a figure that has a
b
as a line of symmetry so a b is a line
of symmetry and this is half the figure
so the rest of the figure is going to
look like this
so the line of symmetry so you literally
just the line of symmetry will look like
that
it's gonna look like that and that
length is equal to that length is equal
to that length is equal to that length
so all four sides are the same
then the entire figure is well all four
sides are the same it's a little bit
skewed so it can't be a square but it's
going to be a
it's going to be
a
rhombus
a rhombus
problem 40.
use the diagram below to answer the
question well we know how to do that
three straight lines intersect to form a
triangle as shown above what is the
measure of angle x well here we just use
a couple of our angle rules if you
watched any of my videos in the past is
what i call the angle game
let's play the angle game we have 60
degrees here this is opposite to the 60
is going to be the same angle so that is
also going to be
60 degrees
right there this is 115 degrees it is
going to be supplementary to this angle
right here which means that this angle
plus 115 is equal to 180. so if we call
this x x plus
115 is equal to 180 subtract 115 from
both sides x is equal to 80 minus 15 is
what 80 minus 10 is 70. 70 minus 5
is 65.
so this angle right here is
65 degrees and this angle let's call
that y
y plus 65 plus 60. and i don't want you
to confuse this x with that x i probably
should have called that some other
number but i'm just saying 65 plus 175
is going to be equal to 180 that's how i
got the 65. they're supplementary and
now let's figure out what this what this
angle y over here is
y
plus 60
plus 65
has to be equal to 180 because they form
a triangle the angles in the triangle
add up to 180. so y plus add these two
together 125 is equal to 180 y is equal
to 180 minus 125.
see 80 minus 25 is what 55. so y is
equal to
55 degrees we're not quite done
y is equal to 55 degrees
now x is supplementary to y so you say x
plus
55 is equal to 180 degrees well we
already know what what plus 55 is equal
to 180 125 so we say x is equal to 180
minus 55 which is equal to 125
degrees
just choice
c right there